[Musique]
et c'est olivier becht qui nous
accompagnent comment allez vous enfin
merci on est ravis de vous accueillir
conseiller départemental dans le canton
de rexam vous êtes le maire aussi de
rixheim et vous êtes conseil
départemental avec votre binôme patricia
fou que ça se passe bien avec elle très
bien voilà vous êtes vous êtes veinards
vous êtes bien tomber les siens a non
seulement on est très bien tourner mais
en plus on a constitué en sort d'une
équipe avec un projet commun c'est
normal qu'on le mette en oeuvre en
équipe et que vous défendiez on s'en va
justement on va partir à la découverte
de ce canton de rixheim au programme la
prise en charge 10 qui touche beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de français et d'aller
à la maladie d'alzheimer 7 à rixheim et
riedisheim et aussi un petit cours de
français vous allez voir un peu
particulier c'est en cours de français
2.0 au collège de rixheim reportage
d'adrien labit
ce coucou il ne risque pas de prendre
les airs mais ils témoignent qu'il ya
plus de 100 ans une bande de joyeux fous
volants écrivez ici l'histoire de
l'aviation c'est en effet sur
l'aérodrome d'habsheim entre 1910 et
1914 fut rétabli nombre de records
aérien par le fabricant d'aéroplan
mulhousien abbiati cette société alors
en pointe de l'innovation ouvrit la voie
à la conquête du ciel la légende raconte
même qu'elle aspire à aller quand une
petite entreprise américaine nommée
boeing
aujourd'hui le canton de habsheim a
certes perdu sa vocation aéronautique
mais demeure un territoire stratégique à
la croisée des axes de communication est
ouest et nord sud une situation
favorable qui en fait l'un des poumons
industriel du département
une dernière danse avant le déjeuner
nous sommes dans l' unité de vie
protégée de l'epagne saint sébastien à
rixheim elle accueille quinze
pensionnaires tous atteints de la
maladie d'alzheimer compte tenu des
particularités de cette pathologie c'est
le service qui s'adresse aux malades et
non l inverse au travers de l'unité de
vie protégée le conseil départemental
marca si la volonté d'apporter des
réponses adaptées aux besoins de nos
personnes âgées et des personnes
dépendantes actuellement le conseil
départemental travail aujourd'hui plus
sur la prise en charge des personnes en
cours à domicile au travers de la
création d accueil de jour et de la mise
en place de prise en charge des aidants
le conseil départemental soutient donc
l'ouverture de structures d'accueil
adaptées aux différents stades de la
maladie c'est le cas ici à riedisheim ou
dans quelques mois ou verra un accueil
de jour un accueil de jour reçoit les
personnes âgées atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer de troubles apparentés ou
les personnes en perte d'autonomie les
accueils de jour servent également à
soulager les familles qui sont souvent
usé fatigué et stressé parce que
s'occuper d'une personne âgée atteinte
de ces pathologies c'est très compliqué
et c'est très usant
retour à et crème au collège dry fût ce
pour un cours de français 2.0 depuis la
rentrée la tablette numérique a fait son
apparition dans le cartable des classes
de 5e et d'une classe de 6e le
département très en pointe sur ce
dossier a soutenu avec l'aide de la
municipalité
la mise en place des équipements le
ministère de l'éducation nationale a
lancé un appel à projet qui visait à
sélectionner 300 collèges dessinée à
être doté de tablettes numériques
le conseil départemental a répondu
favorablement et a retenu trois collèges
le collège saint-exupéry à mulhouse le
collège berlioz à colmar et
effectivement le collège dry fusent ici
à rixheim ça sera poursuivie sur trois
ans donc la rentrée 2016 ça sera
également nouveau les classes de 5e qui
sont équipés et en 2017 sera et classe
de 5ème plus une partie des classes de
6e l'expérimentation est porté par une
équipe enseignante très motivé et c'est
peut être ici à rixheim que s'inventent
l'école de demain le polycopié c'est
pour mercredi voilà olivier becht
conseil départemental canton de rixe à
nous elle nous dira c c'est là que se
fait l'école de demain en tout cas la
mise en place des tablettes pour les
collégiens et bien c'est essentiel pour
vous pour d'utiliser les nouvelles
technologies extrêmement jade c'est
important mais oui moi je pense que le
plus beau cadeau qu'on puisse faire à
nos jeunes aujourd'hui c'est de leur
donner les moyens de survivre dans ce
monde de demain et les meilleurs atouts
ce seront la maîtrise du numérique et
les langues étrangères celui qui perdra
fakih qui maîtrisera l'outil numérique
et celui qui parlera à un certain nombre
de langues étrangères pourra se promener
à peu près partout sur la planète et
pourra accéder à une multitude de
métiers et ensuite la spécialisation ça
prend souvent sur le tas comme on dit
mais à linverse ce qu'ils ne
maîtriseront pas le numérique ce qui ne
parleront pas les langues étrangères
auront un vrai handicap sur le marché du
travail dans ce début de xxième siècle
très exposé aux écrans aujourd'hui avec
les jeux vidéo la télé tablettes
smartphones on est tous un peu ans
jeunes exposés aux écrans est ce que
c'est vraiment le rôle de l'école d'en
rajouter alors il est probable
effectivement que les jeunes passent
beaucoup de temps devant devant les
écrans in progress être trop la télé
sauf alsace20 bien sûr où d'autres ou
d'autres smartphones ensuite la question
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on peut le
faire de manière pédagogique est ce
qu'on peut le faire de manière
intelligente
l'objectif de l'école c'est encore une
fois de donner les atouts aux jeunes
c'est à dire la maîtrise de cet outil
numérique il faut voir aussi le côté on
va dire un peu pédagogique de l'outil
c'est à dire la capacité de faire de
l'interactif on n'est pas exclusivement
sur internet à les tablettes n'ont pas
besoin d'être connecté au wifi en
permanence mais ça permet aussi aux
professeurs de faire découvrir des
matières comme l'histoire les
mathématiques de manière plus ludique
plus pédagogique aujourd'hui voilà est
davantage effectivement avec les
vecteurs de d'aujourd'hui et encore
davantage de demain vous défendez
réellement numérique est ce que cette
action pourrait s'étendre à d'autres
collèges c'est un peu l'objectif 1 comme
le disait patricia fuchs nous sommes
collège dit préfigurateurs un savon été
choisi parmi plusieurs établissements en
alsace pour lancer cette expérimentation
le président de la république a dit
l'état mettra un euro pour chaque euro
investi par les collectivités locales
ensuite la vraie question c'est de
savoir si au niveau du conseil
départemental nous aurons les moyens
financiers compte tenu des baisses de
dotations de l'état pour équiper
l'ensemble des collégiens du département
mais si on en a les moyens je ne doute
pas que l'assemblée soit à le faire
après le numérique question économique
forte
composante industrielle dans votre
canton ya psa île napoléon est ce que la
question économique pour vous c'est
toujours au coeur de votre action alors
elle l'est plus que jamais même si le
conseil départemental à travers la loi
notre qui a été votée l'année dernière
va perdre fin 2016 sa compétence
économique néanmoins le conseiller
départemental il est animateur d'un
territoire c'est quand même avec les
maires les personnes vers lesquels les
citoyens mais plus encore les chefs
d'entreprise se dirigent lorsqu'il ya un
problème par exemple un problème d'accès
à internet ont parlé du numérique à
l'instant l'aménagement des zones
d'activités économiques
les mecs tout ça ce sont des questions
que les entreprises se pose est donc le
conseiller économique c'est aussi le
développement économique c'est aussi de
longues peines et l'innovation dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure avec le lilla
merabet voilà et le conseil
départemental il est un peu animateurs
de ceux de ce territoire où il va et
nous l'avons fait avec le conseil
départemental du haut rhin et celui du
bas rhin créer une grande agence
régionale enfin il a sienne aujourd'hui
pour l'aménagement et surtout pour le
développement économique un la nouvelle
à dire axa de la fusion du quart et de
la dira donc on est plus que jamais au
service des entreprises et le conseil
départemental demeurera un interlocuteur
privilégié des entreprises pour leur
permettre d'accéder aux dispositifs
d'innovation de financement et de
transformation de ces de ses usines on
le voit psa est dans un processus
aujourd'hui de transformation
exceptionnelle avec plus de 650 millions
d'euros investis solvay sur la bande
rhénane et apporter du chômage c'est
dommage a aussi grimper sa valeur que
voilà ça veut dire qu'il faut forcément
être attractif et faire revenir lancer
d'autres centres c'est à dire qu'il faut
agir sur les deux domaines il faut agir
sur la transformation des entreprises
existantes c'est le cas aujourd'hui de
psa de solvay etc qui se modernise parce
que les entreprises qui se modernise
rompt pas dans cinq ans malheureusement
seront sont mortes et en même temps la
modernisation peut apporter
effectivement des baisses d'emploi
lorsque c'est de la robotisation qui
prend le pas ou d'une mairie qui prend
le pas et dont il faut en parallèle
implanter les entreprises qui créeront
également les nouveaux emplois de demain
kandé conseil départemental est ce qu'on
est une sorte de vrp de son territoire
qu'est-ce qu'on est l'animateur qui son
territoire mais comme avait repéré au
vent son territoire qu'on a besoin de le
faire dit alors on le vend mais on n'est
pas seuls à le faire on est dans le cas
des intercommunalités on est avec les
maires les élus locaux le conseil
départemental c'est celui qui exerce
pour le département un certain nombre de
compétences on l'a vu sur la dépendance
on aurait pu parler également du social
ou des routes des collèges
mais c'est également celui qui va jouer
les go between entre
les acteurs de terrain et puis d'autres
institutions comme la région qui sont
plus éloignées où l'état qui est plus
éloigné engagez-vous c'était les cris de
frédéric bierry engagez vous ces voix-là
faut que les citoyens et les entreprises
c'est ce que nous faisons il faut que
les aima la vie au quotidien merci à
vous ça a été un plaisir de vous
recevoir je propose deux choses un petit
instant